[Applause]
who are you my name is Sarah Connor I
never seen one like you before almost
human
I am human
why do you care what happens to her
because I was her who was Sarah when we
pick up with her here's she's broken
does that surprise you
she is truly a broken devastated woman I
can't give too much away but she's lost
her purpose so she's pretty dangerous
how would you feel like this film maybe
separates itself from the first two
movies well I'm the hell of a lot older
I think that it will actually tie in
really beautifully with the first two
films because we are carrying the story
forward from the second film and it just
has that feel you know one of the first
two films that really I think should
should should be pretty seamless what
was the first conversation when they
came to you and they say we want you to
come back to terminate who was it with
it was with Jim Cameron and it actually
took me probably six weeks to decide to
do it
I wasn't like okay I'm in I I really I
think about some thought that I want to
return I I spent so much of my career
kind of trying to be something other
than Sarah O'Connor because one doesn't
want to just do one thing but all these
years later it felt like there was much
more that I could say that it wasn't
just gonna be like
the proverbial you know whipping the
dead horse but that there and there and
indeed there it is such a rich canvas to
perform in that I finally decided to do
it you know we're asking everybody of
those first two movies do you have a
favorite moment
that's a really good question that I've
never actually had to ask before in
terms of like where I was at the time I
think that first film you're terminated
because that was just day nine and ogro
and I it was covered with bruises it
just took so much the hand that's coming
in that is like actually because if we
didn't have anything else in those days
was a 250 pound alarm that they're
throwing up my neck and the sense of
just danger I'd just get through this it
was very very authentic but finally when
slipping in you know fruit juice at the
factory it was just it was very
authentic you have a favorite moment
from one of those two films that you
just loved when you got about the milk
carton and two and then Paxton my boy
Paxton a recipe in one at the Griffith
Park observatory tell us just a little
bit quick how you play in the film how
we factor in Terminator Ben just you
know trying to you know trying to do
something different but not not reinvent
the wheel because there's so much that
Arnold was successful with and so much
that Robert successful with so I just
tried to define what worked and then
just try to elevate it a little bit if I
can where I can and
it's an evolution of the other
terminators can't say play in I play
grace I'm a an enhanced human that shows
up in Mexico City on a mysterious
mission to protect Danny Rambo so it's
played by Natalia Reyes and that's the
lion I can say over the first you know
this is a continuation of the first two
films so we're asking everybody you have
a moment from one of those two films
that like you remember the most that you
loved the most
yeah it's not it's the same one everyone
has which is Linda's guns just like
appearing in camera and her slowly
pulling yourself up in a pull up it's
very inspiring what did that mean to you
growing up well I didn't see it until
about a year ago so it was really hue I
finally saw this moment that everyone
else has seen her entire lives
it's just cool seeing a strong woman
who's not trying to present herself on
screen was just like going and pursuing
and acting and yeah I think she's I
think she means a lot to the history of
female actually stars how would you say
this film sort of separates itself from
the other two well I mean it's it's a
direct sequel to the first two movies
but it's thirty years later and so
there's this there's a darkness in that
and this woman that's gone through so
much than a hammer Sarah Connor we start
at the end of the second one and all the
person choice at the end of the second
was so wildly different from the one at
the end of the first and then who does
she become after thirty years of living
like that and that idea was so
interesting to explore and then that's
obviously part of a much bigger story
but I think the Sarah Connor connection
it's just so interesting and watching
her
over time
you